- That was the hardest part.
- I know, right?
(laughing)
- Now, we love "The Crown."
- Yeah we do.
(bell dings)
- Big fans of "The Crown"
since the beginning.
(bell dings)
- Something funny?
- We could go on all day about
how good it is. (bell dings)
(building orchestral music)
(humming tone)
- [Amy] Do you think mom
would like that carpet?
- I think I might get one of those.
- Yep, same.
- Where's the queen?
Ah!
Oh, they're comparing the
two actresses side by side.
- That's him from "Outlander.
He's a bad man.
- Right, Dylan, I'm off.
- I'm off.
- I feel that watching "The Crown"
enhances my vocabulary.
- If you wanna mimic the royal family,
you go, "Extraordinary."
- Aw there he is.
Reminds me of me.
(laughing)
- I'm not sad anymore.
- You were the compass
that steered and directed me.
- Bow from the neck and
walk back towards me.
- Oh, the rules isn't it.
- This must be really weird.
- I'm aware of your
affection for my predecessor,
and doubtless you'd have
preferred him to have continued.
- Oh, don't talk to your
queen like that, how dare you?
Little swine.
- What reaction do you
think I would get then,
if I went out in the time
there and now with that outfit?
(chuckles)
With the pearls on.
- Who do you think you are, the Queen?
(coughing)
- Oh no.
- Winston is dead.
- Oh my gosh, it tried to kill me.
(blowing nose)
- I've tried many times.
- Who's dead?
- Oh, probably Winston.
(coughing)
- Sorry.
- I think it was the first kind of funeral
I'd ever witnessed and it
was such a big thing on TV.
- Yeah.
It's quite intense, really.
- To a five year old--
- I think it's the whole scene of it.
- It was too much.
- Yeah.
- I can't believe all this
popcorn is coming out my nose.
This is unreal.
- Carrie, Winston's dead.
- Winston's dead?
- We don't have a Russian
spy in Downing Street.
- We do have one in Buckingham Palace.
- What?
- [Anthony] But can anything
ever be fully understood?
- He's the spy.
- Scandalous.
- But she's not happy is she, christ.
- That's the face she pulled when she had
to marry David Mitchell in "Peep Show."
(laughing)
- It's horrible, it's horrible.
- We're over the hump.
- We're over the hump, Soph.
He's so horrible.
- Our marriage.
- To Anthony Blunt.
(crowd applauding)
- How could he even stand there?
- It is he who has
curated this exhibition.
I have particularly enjoyed the portrait,
which turned out to have another person
lurking up beneath the surface.
(laughing)
- Oh.
That is clever.
I love this parallel language.
- None of us will be able to trust
or look at anything in
the same way ever agan.
- Pow.
(laughing)
- You would be well to
reflect on your own position.
- How dare you?
- You may remember at the height of the
Profumo sex scandal.
I was gonna say, I know who
you've been sleeping with.
(gasps)
That was huge.
- They're gonna bring this up.
- Bastard!
(intense music)
- Does he still live there?
No, no he's leaving, that's him leaving.
- Now he's coming in.
- How could you do that?
- He got away with it.
- Oh my god, they let
him work and just retire,
and nothing happened to him.
- Wow.
- That was very good.
- Loving it.
♪ One of those things ♪
- The mood is definitely changing.
- A little bit heavier.
- That was really good.
- Yeah.
- Acting wise, it's always on point.
- This is where I go,
"I've gotta watch the next one."
I'll be up to stupid o'clock morning
on a school night.
- Yeah, there's just so
much more to come, I think.
There's just so much
more intrigue to come.
♪ It was just one of those nights ♪